das hier ist die sportstadt dass frieden
das hier ist 000 homo fürs alter da
setze ich da so ein ding und er boxt
mich einfach junge das kann doch nicht
sein immer wenn ich irgendwas zeige
werde ich geboxt
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen runde survival games games
zusammen mit euch auf die hsbc zusammen
mit mir alleine
ich hab grad geduscht man haare sind
total im eimer bzw sehen wahrscheinlich
so aus wie sonst auch immer sich so
gerade in der fei scam aber die sind
halt einfach nur dass jetzt nichts drin
deswegen die sind weil sie nicht egal
darum geht's doch nicht und zwar geht es
darum dass ich
gestern kam ja kein video flughafen hier
kamen ein video und jetzt ist das hier
so eine art so damit ich heute damit
wenigstens video mache mache ich jetzt
dass sie ebenso eine kleine runde
survival games hier für euch warum das
ganze
besonders kleines wird werde ich jetzt
auch noch so ein bisschen sagen gleich
wenn du jetzt mal losgegangen ist
und zwar möchte ich drei sachen sagen
und zwar erstens erste video auf luca
film gemacht über dinge die ich hasse
ich habe ja schon mal 20 fakten über
mich gemachten video 1 ich habe schon
mal ein video gemacht wo ich so 20
fakten über mich so gesagt hat wie zum
beispiel weiß nicht was ich so mag und
blabla ich wieder meine route auf dieser
map das ist jetzt ein video nur über
sachen die ich nicht so sehr mag also
die sich mehr oder weniger halt asse
habe ich halt da in dem video gesagt
habe ich euch den link mal oben in die
beschreibung gepackt und ich weiß nicht
ob ich hier auch irgendwo ein blend ich
glaube ich hab's ja auch irgendwo
eingeblendet oder so könnte einfach
draufklicken jetzt auf meinem real
f-kanal was einige auch immer noch nicht
verstanden haben viele schreiben immer
noch in die kommentare
halo cardillo blabla du hast ja hier
du machst ja gar kein real life mehr auf
konter ja das ist alles auf luca filmt
jetzt youtube.com flash luca film viduka
geschrieben solltet ihr mittlerweile
wissen ob man hier ist immer eine dings
eigentlich drin
ein schwert aber egal letztes ich weiß
noch letzte runde die hab ich glaube ich
auch die habe ich mal ja die habe ich im
hintergrund gepackt beiden spielen mit
anderen glaube ich was übrigens mega gut
angekommen ist dadurch deutlich sechs
schwerter oder so das war mega heftig
hier übrigens auf dieser map ist wasser
giftig und dahinter das wasser heißt
euch mal zeigen da rein und ich halt
schaden scheiße doch meine kiste ich
hätte eventuell erste kiste gehen wollen
blöde als nicht so irgendwie drauf
moment muss ich ein gegner
sauber hat sich nicht so ganz gelohnt
aber hier sind natürlich noch viel mehr
kosten und zwar da oben habe ich einen
drauf ich komme ich von ihrer von neda
ist gar keine rolle
ach so ja ich möchte jetzt kein team
machen sorry also ich mach eigentlich
immer mega gern mit euch team und so was
alles aber ich möchte jetzt einfach mal
ne runde wohl weil alle meine marseille
konnte ist so schlecht ja weil ich immer
mit ihm mache und dann ich bin ja immer
so lieb in survival games ich bin ja nie
so ja ich bringe euch jetzt alle um
so bin ich eigentlich nie drauf deswegen
eigentlich bin ich gar nicht so schlecht
in bleu de ja ne he also das video auf
luca film da ist halt jetzt mal wieder
live zweite sache ich habe bei einem
kumpel gepennt und wir haben halt fifa
ultimate team gezockt und alles möglich
das kirmes und alles mögliche bei uns
zurzeit deswegen
dieses komplette lange wochenende bei
mir ist einfach mega durchgeplant mit
dahin fahren und da hinfahren und blabla
eventuell egal ist jetzt egal jedenfalls
kalter krieg nicht mehr guck mal was ist
denn das korridor ist schlicht die jungs
kommen dann drehe mich jetzt mal und
dann schicke ich hier alle durch so dann
nehme ich immer den panzer mit ihr
werdet denn eisen schwer getroffen weil
ich so geträumt bin
haha was jetzt ich weiß nicht ich glaube
dann sind auch noch kisten ich hoffe
daneben schreibt man alle konietzko in
die kommentare und das überall bei allen
videos jetzt einmal jetzt mal so ein
flashmob conny ist kein blut conny ist
ein profi
es schreibt jetzt überall hin auf alle
micro videos die ihr guckt kurz gibt ja
viele leute die so dings gemacht haben
so scheiße los
die so etwas gab sender viva la rum
gespielt gab ist es gab halt richtig
viele sachen machen wir das jetzt mal
conny ist kein upps pro schreibt das mal
bei den weg hat guckt dann starten wir
zusammen einen kleinen flashmob mehr
oder weniger alter das ist geil ich habe
vielleicht sogar schon level dann kann
ich verzaubern
aber wo kann ich denn verzaubern ich
weiß gar nicht wo hier sind auch noch
kisten leitet ist es also leute die
route hier ne die kann ich echt jedem
nur empfehlen es ist hammergeil an
frasers und zwar was ich aber weiß ich
eigentlich quatschen wollte war das neue
projekt von simon wo ich jetzt eventuell
wo ich erst mal ein paar infos hier raus
und zwar habe ich glaube ich am anfang
als ich ihm dass er gerade ist alles so
auf deswegen ich glaube ich habe am
anfang eine anmerkung 1 gemacht dass sie
bis hierhin zwischen könnt weil alle die
was über das neue projekt von mir halt
so wissen wollen sich aber für mich
nicht interessieren sondern nur das
projekt die götter anhalt jetzt haben
wir uns halt hierhin geschwitzt und zwar
er hat simon da gestern video gemacht
das hat mir gestern einmal angeguckt um
halb betrunkenen zustand was dann so
alles beim neuen projekt ist wir wussten
natürlich schon so ein paar sachen zum
beispiel wussten schon sehr lange dass
exit ist ich hab's halt immer versucht
so ein bisschen zu verheimlichen
leider die kommentare geschrieben am
headset blabla ich hab mir gesagt hey
hey was exit möglich aber jetzt hat die
man das halt auch schon jetzt schon
gesagt
schon seit längerem steht mittlerweile
fest wird hexe sein es wird mit mit sehr
sehr vielen anderen seinen
feuerwehr gewesen hat es dabei also
zander ist dabei schaffte es dabei ich
bin dabei ich bin nicht ab
doch ich bin dabei komme zur onyx simon
kimm noch alles rot ist also auf jeden
fall eine menge leute ich glaube 21
insgesamt fall ist wird drei städte
geben
sieben bewohner vorstadt scheiße ist
wenn ich mich zum crafting table
gegangen quadratmeter ein brot
gekräftigt holtmann
es gibt wie viele leben noch sechs
wibank dort have been reached die pointe
es wird drei städte a7 bewohner geben
und jede startet quasi von unseren
eigenen könig mehr oder weniger wenn man
das könig nennen kann also ich werde
natürlich der king sein das ist ganz
klar natürlich wie auch sonst muss man
halt dann auswählen kann ich das nicht
taten
leider pizza.de brate das für mich gut
als wir halt drei städte geben die ist
wenn wenn hier so die anfangs stadt ist
wird sich zeigen
ich mache das man hier ganz kurz auf und
zwar hier
so also ich hab das ja auch noch beiden
die man gesehen dass die notizen von
luca film video das hier ist die
sportstadt dass frieden das hier ist die
homo fürs alter da setze ich da so ein
ding und er boxt mich einfach junge das
kann doch nicht sein immer wenn ich
irgendwas zeige werde ich geboxt
alter ist das game vor allem von robo
der so sieht dass ich nur rumstehen bin
und dann werde ich nur geboxt von dem
linke wir an sich ist das denn bitte
ich laufe jetzt diese ein bisschen rum
ich muss gleich erstmal abchecken ob ich
irgendwo links habe
marco kebbe tot okay ich bin tot leute
da kann ich nix für ich schwöre ich
hätte den geboxt schwierig hat ihn
umgebracht
ich werde einfach geboxt wenn ich
irgendwo rum stehe wie scheiße ich war
afk dieser feigling
also ich hätte auch den getötet aber er
hält alles gemeistert
na gut und man ist das scheiß verlieren
hier wieder hier
das ist die friedensstadt dass frieden
drin dann ist hier eine stadt dass eine
stadt
und da es eine stadt sagen wir jetzt ich
bin zum beispiel hier dann sind
irgendwie paar andere und hier sind paar
andere und ich bin halt dann hier und
ich habe hier frieden mit denen die hier
sind und das ist eine andere staaten das
eine andere stadt und hier haben
allgemein alle frieden da kann man sich
zu treffen und zur scheiße bauen
und hier ist zum beispiel durch eine
wüstenstadt hier ist eine normale stadt
und hier sonne statt
ich weiß es nicht jedenfalls ich dachte
wusste war nein ich würde mich gewandt
wir wurden um ein baby weggenommen aber
das wird mir nie wieder zurückgegeben
keine ahnung
jetzt mal hier lief so und diese städte
können hat entweder in frieden
miteinander leben die kann allerdings
nicht auch einmal bekämpfen man darf
allerdings nicht sich einfach so
gegenseitig beklauen und so was alles
also so wie simon dass da vorgetragen
hat in dem video von ihm also ich will
ich das kann alles zusammenfassen
damit ihr dass sie auch mitbekommt dass
simon das daran gedacht hat ist es echt
super geplant finde ich alles also es
hört sich echt alles mega hammer geil an
und man muss sagen dass er schon eine
menge was steht da denn dieses thailand
apicella disabled ja das ist gut dass
das alles echt schon schon gut durch
plant das muss ich sagen und auch mit
regeln und wenn man dann mal eine regel
nicht mit nicht beachtet wird man dann
halt rausgeschmissen wirklich aus dem
projekt also das wirklich dann stieg der
verlauf ist
wirklich strikt nach regeln gespielt
wird und nicht dass wenn einer 30 -
setzt 30 94 news und die ganze stadt in
die luft sprengen dann wird man halt
auch aus dem projekt gewandt und was
alles also nichts gegen dich jena aber
hat sieht man halt gesagt und das ist
auf jeden fall ganz gut und ich freue
mich darauf und das wird dann bei mir
wieder so ein projekt seien sowohl dann
jeden tag eine folge von kommen wird
oder contra van wieder die zeit muss
simon hat doch gesagt dass irgendwie
einmal gesagt weiß nicht dass es uns
alle super gefällt also ich habe noch
nichts davon mitbekommen deswegen kann
ich dass er so nicht zu sagen ich weiß
noch nicht wo er das her nimmt aber es
hat sich auf jeden fall super an und
dickes lob da und bla bla es ist auf
jeden fall hammer geil und ich muss
sagen ich freue mich einfach drauf und
natürlich sagen freunde die wir uns dann
nächsten mal wieder bzw morgen da kommt
nicht was sehr sehr witzig ist wenn ich
das noch schaffen irgendwie zu machen
sonst würde ich sagen durchgefallen hat
könnte einen durchbruch geben meine
stimme zu hoch wie sonst was weil ich
gerade ein bisschen helium genommen hat
von einem luftballon gerade habe ich bin
ich hier
innerhalb von millisekunden unter meinen
tisch gegangen hat das gezogen bin dann
wieder hoch gekommen dass sie gar nicht
gesehen deswegen typs kranke